négocier d'égal à égal un partenariat
entre un québec souverain et le canada
je compte sur vous pourquoi risquer ni
faiblir les québec la séparation
sinon octobre 1995 les québécois doivent
choisir leur pays
c'est la deuxième fois en 15 ans qui
sont appelés à se prononcer sur la
souveraineté du québec
je vous ai bien compris je tente un de
dire à la prochaine fois après la
défaite du oui en 1981 le québec subi
une série de revers
le rapatriement de la constitution sans
son aval en 1982 puis les échecs
successifs de l'accord du lac meech en
1990 le québec est aujourd'hui et pour
toujours une société distincts et
l'accord de charlottetown deux ans plus
tard le mécontentement nourrit les
nationalistes et mène en 1994 à
l'élection de jacques parizeau
en juin 1995 le parti québécois le bloc
et la nouvelle action démocratique du
québec forment une coalition pour le oui
la campagne référendaire est déclenchée
le 1er octobre
[Applaudissements]
sow
les foules sont magnétisés par le
charisme de lucien bouchard
bientôt le camp du oui lui confie le
rôle de porte étendard à votre nom nous
rejetons version de la séparation
le camp du non sens le tapis lui glisser
sous les pieds
[Musique]
ces efforts culmine avec le loving un
grand rassemblement au centre ville de
montréal le 27 octobre
des dizaines de milliers de canadiens
viennent de partout au pays
dire leur amour envers le québec le
women actuellement un congé 1398 voit le
soir du vote
l'ambiance est tendue en début de soirée
le oui est en avance puis à mesure que
se poursuit le dépouillement le nom
remonte tranquillement la pente pour
finalement l'emporter
radio canada prévoit si la tendance du
voc se maintient que c'est l'option du
non qui rapportera ce référendum mais en
démocratie le peuple a toujours raison
ce soir il n'y a qu'un seul gagnant
c'est lui le peuple
la défaite est amère pour jacques
parizeau
c'est vrai qu'on était battu au fond
marcquois à l'argent pillé vote ethnique
échangés
devant ce québec divisée comme jamais il
annonce le lendemain qu'il quitte son
poste de premier ministre
hier le québec glv de vous il lui
restera pas à faire il a l'élan voulut
jamais les indépendantistes n'auront été
si près du but elle viendra bientôt j'en
suis profondément convaincu